For me, I grew up in this Novartis area.
For me, it is very important to
work in this area and it is to be able to
help our Hispanic citizens
who are in this area because it is very
important. We, as the
Metropolitan Metro Police, depend
on everyone's trust.  not only of
Hispanic citizens but of all
citizens so that they have that confidence that if
they are victims of a crime or
something, don't be afraid to report that
crime.
This event that we are here today is
called fresh water with a police officer.
We created this event  to
try to be more involved with
our Hispanic citizens everything has
gone well so far we have had
people come in here and have
a fresh water with us they
have asked us questions that perhaps they would not have asked us
another day if
we were not here today